it's easy to have a pretty negative view
of drugs the news is always going on
about police raids on drug dealers kids
tripping dangerous Lea raves overdoses
and Rehab it goes without saying things
can go for if icky wrong around drugs
but our intense awareness of the
negatives is in danger of creating a
misleadingly narrow view of the subject
drugs are at best serious dignified
noble and important and we need more of
them in our lives the real issue is we
don't have a correct sense of what a
drug is and what the drugs might be that
we in particular truly need essentially
a drug is a thing anything that alters
your mood acting via either the body or
the senses to make an impact upon the
mind we've come to associate the impact
of drugs with a heightening of a
particular band of emotional states the
weird The Escapist the hyperactive and
the ecstatically relaxed but in truth
there are far more interesting fruitful
and positive directions in which we
should want our minds to be altered were
only at the start of understanding the
possibility of drugs the task of a drug
is simply to alter moods in any positive
direction compatible with fulfilling
one's highest ambitions so we need drugs
to help us to be more self analytical
more hopeful less prone to irritability
more politically tolerant and better at
listening to other people especially
partners when they have legitimate
complaints against us fortunately there
are a lot more things that are drugs
than we ordinarily suppose we need to
move away from the idea of drugs as
pills that someone gives you at a party
when you're 16 that will make you feel
tired say could possibly kill you and
make you look cool and shock your parts
the word drug happens to be sitting on a
crucially important and large idea the
generation of benign and positive states
of mind through the use of external
physical resources any properly accurate
list of drugs we have available should
now include the following pomegranate
juice
Coffee stimulates but on the right
dosage just squeezed orange juice with a
touch of lemon briefly strengthens the
will and makes us more able to face
tricky tasks the much less known
pomegranate juice has a soothing calming
effect which helps one be less prickly
around perceived insults and slights the
paintings of Caspar David Friedrich this
physical object titled morning recently
burger by the German 19th century
romantic artists Caspar David Friedrich
is a drug that hangs on a wall and it's
intended to produce an expanded state of
consciousness in which the pain of
immediate troubles is lessened by a
euphoric recognition of the immensity of
nature and the cosmos Emmental cheese
it's mild savory taste and yielding but
not crumbly texture quickly bring on a
feeling of replete natales a quick
anxiety reducer like chocolate and hot
buttered toast amytal is an Envy
suppressing drug Mozart's Aria Sarvis C
il Vento this musical drug briefly
induces a heightened state of tenderness
towards strangers and a mood of
generosity towards one's own and others
stupidity when it comes to relationships
of course the precise effects of these
substances will vary from one person to
the next
so a key task with these and all drugs
is to get good at working out what we
really need to optimize our own
functioning what might be a crucial
corrective for one person would be
deeply unhelpful for another in wiser
society than ours we would have drug
advisors available at hotels shopping
malls and online people who would do a
full audit of our natures and come up
with extended menus for what sort of
drugs might be most suitable for are
given characters and in what doses and
at what times of day we should take them
in the past
ambitious societies have looked very
seriously at drugs and the thing they
did was to organize drug use into
rituals a very popular drug tea was
employed in Buddhist ceremonies in Japan
from the 13th century onwards the drug
was used to promote focus concentration
and a feeling of strong connection to
other human beings you
might have to sit in a particular way
taking your tea drunk wait patiently to
be served and consume a very specific
quantity while contemplating the branch
of a pine tree in the wind the ancient
Greeks were also very interested in
drugs their ritual known as the
Dionysian mysteries was built around the
highly structured use of red wine as
part of a religious festival
participants would drink and dance in
search of a sense of collective
belonging as decreed by the god Dionysus
by making what might otherwise descend
into binge drinking into a religious
festivals the Greeks cleverly directed
the immense power of alcohol towards the
most beneficial states of mind instead
of being a reason for getting into an
argument with one's spouse or messing up
a wedding speech wine became an occasion
for fostering trust and loyalty between
citizens in the city moods play an
immense role in our lives and yet we
tend to be haphazard in the way we
identify and deal with them at present
we play around with moods with hugely
clumsy and dangerous instruments with
drugs that we hardly understand and that
can have a devastating impact on our
well-being we need to broaden our sense
of what a drug is allow Mozart and
Emmental cheese into the mix and then
have a system that correctly directs
people to what might be the right drugs
for them with their flourishing be the
end goal we're still only at the dawn of
learning how to take drugs properly
we're sure to learn to be far better
drug takers in the future
you